are you willing
your paycheck david yeah are you willing
to my friends at home i see a lot of
people commenting thank you for being
here are you willing to get paid in
bitcoin your paycheck like indefinitely
yeah yeah um
part of it
all of it are you willing to get paid in
ethereum
yeah again part of it not okay are you
willing to get paid in dogecoin [ __ ] no
okay
so there's a limit to how much crypto
you would accept as part of your
paycheck yeah i guess obviously i'll
take the heavyweights but dogecoin
okay good point well here's the deal
here's an article from cryptoslate
basically tracking how much money people
are willing to get paid
in crypto their paycheck i'm talking
paychecks yeah apparently 65 of
employees responded that they would at
least somewhat willing
to receive compensation in crypto 28
said sign me up i'm very willing i'm in
now 63 of a millennial said yeah i can
view getting paid as uh
in crypto and that's like that's a nice
perk i can see that happening
so
uh when asked which cryptos they would
like to see in their paychecks the
majority of working americans said in
this order bitcoin
followed by ethereum followed by
dogecoin what are most people gonna get
the
third fourth like
0.0002 of a bitcoin it just it's look
these are this is this is a i don't know
if there's any this is even happening
right now but if i'm that person and you
said look uh five percent you know how
like they say five percent of your
paycheck that's going to go to your 401k
cool all right great now within that
maybe all right one percent is going to
go to bitcoin or five percent bitcoin
cool our portion of your paycheck is
gonna go to crypto i think a lot of
people would be okay with that yeah
bitcoin sure give me a little bit it's
risky i get it you give me a thousand
now my thousand seven fifty oh my 750 is
now 500. oh my 500 is now 1200 okay all
right it's
yeah that's bitcoin for you yeah okay
not because elon musk tweeted something
well that's something different exactly
so it's like then you got ethereum which
you know i like it it's a little less
known than bitcoin obviously a little
less risky yeah i'll take some of that
now dogecoin
people are willing to accept dogecoin on
their paycheck let me tell you something
the only people that should be willing
to accept dogecoin are dogs
okay
like if you're willing to accept
dogecoin as a payment
you are living on the edge listen you
are rich i have a sketch coin like i i i
have those got some deutsche because i
don't wanna dude i don't want in 20
years people that bought bitcoin
and then sold it because they were like
oh they had a buddy that did a podcast
with with about financial health yeah
they were like dude you have those yeah
bitcoin come on that's a weird that's
good and now look at it and i'll look at
it okay no never and you never know cost
me nothing okay how much did it cost you
nothing i'd rather all right well here's
my advice to my dogecoin friends out
there before you get dogecoin or even
before you get bitcoin yeah get yourself
some index fund get some s p 500. that's
the main course yeah and if you want to
have some bitcoin on the side cool more
power too that's a dave having some
ethereum okay more power to you yeah
dogecoin you don't want to get paint
dogecoin that's it i said it
um this could be a tom zenner moment
we'll revisit this in 10 years and see
if dogecoin is worth yeah
um well look
i'm just saying there's some types of
crypto i would be willing to get paid in
you know who also wants to get paid in
crypto some high profile people
what do you see here who's the best
quarterback of all time all the time uh
easily easily
tom brady tom brady you're not even a
football guy tom brady
check this out
he's somebody who's willing to get paid
in crypto oh yeah tom brady admits quote
unquote he'd love for part of his
monster nfl salary paid in crypto and he
thinks
it's an amazing thing yeah okay well
that's different let's take a picture of
this because his salary would probably
be a couple dose coins
i mean the average person would get
point zero zero zero
or at least what you're gonna get one
like what do you make how much is
dogecoin right now uh like 25 cents so
what is it
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry did he say
dogecoin he i'll let me get into the
crypto 25 i'm sorry i'm going to coin
obviously his salary would be point 25
cents what is dogecoin at right now i
don't care i'm not about bitcoin like
yeah obviously he would want to get paid
in bitcoin
point 20 yeah point 20. no but bitcoin
obviously he would i wouldn't i mean
part of it but not all of it anyway
here's the deal tom brady says look he
starred in a commercial recently for uh
none other than the crypto exchange
platform ftx which is now what was the
miami heat arena the american airlines
arenas now is ftx i remember driving
past the arena like what the who the
hell is ftx i know there it is
so he said look i support crypto i'm in
it i think it's a real deal and i'm
willing to put my money where my digital
wallet is interesting so he says quote
unquote i'd love to request to get paid
in some crypto and get paid in some
bitcoin or ethereum or even solana
tokens that's solana it's a thing that
we're starting to hear more about yeah
so
anyway crypto like this stuff is
starting
to happen crypto has already started to
invade the sports world you know you
know what teams are already starting to
accept it i know you're not a big sports
guy dallas mavericks mark cuban
sacramento kings out there in uh
the capital of california near silicon
valley out that way oakland a's our
friend billy bean who just did the the
vault they're all accepting bitcoin as
payment all of them
um there's even actually a guy in the
nfl his name is ro russell o'coon yeah
aku ng he took half his salary in
bitcoin this year
now since he signed his contract
bitcoin's uh
kind of gone down
but we'll see he said half
um one thing i know about crypto when
big time people you talked about elon
musk sending a tweet yeah they move
markets tom brady exactly
can he move markets i don't know i think
so i think once you hear it that's like
a huge um
advocacy for for bitcoin if you hear tom
brady man i mean
i'm gonna buy some some bitcoin because
he's gonna get paid in it why wouldn't i
want to be somewhat you know
so i've been pretty explicit on this the
big boys are putting five
three to five to eight percent of their
portfolio into crypto give it a shot
yeah you don't want to go 50 50 with the
russell o'coon you don't want to put 99
of your money into crypto these are
that's my opinion yeah okay
it's a a um
it's an asset right that you can you
know risky
risk you know risk in return okay i get
it risk and reward
um
but joe you can't go all in on that you
can't that's just my opinion yeah no way
i agree um
anyway so that's tom brady homeboy is a
winner
[Music]
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broke
[Music]